tonight we honor a man who has carried
into the world of film a name already
lustrous in the dot of painting Jean
Renoir who appears as a child in many of
his father's priceless canvases over
seventy years ago when he grew up he
took his own canvas the motion picture
screen now in the following five decades
he has left behind him a body of
masterpieces just as his father did from
the beginning Jean Renoir created films
with intense individuality serving as
his own writer designer producer
director whose lyric I Petach realism
his trust and above all his compassion
his deep and true understanding of life
marked all his work he says in his
biography my chief aim was the only the
only one I have been pursuing ever since
I started to make films to express the
common humanity of men
someone said about wrong he is a lover
of mankind in all its nobility and
despite its folly in the world he is
known as the best of man in the cinema
universe he is a living God Jean Renoir
unfortunately is not here tonight with
us but I hope that he sees us can you
hear me wrong it is a great honor to
have been chosen to present you with
this special honorary award for
exceptionally distinguished service to
the art of motion pictures
in gratitude for all you have taught the
tribes of young movie makers and the
audience is all over the world I stand
here to say with them thank you we love
you Jean